now we're going to tackle a very
interesting optimization problem so
we're given a length of wire that is a
hundred feet long so this distance right
over here is 100 and it could be 100
feet hundred meters but we'll just call
it a hundred feet along just annoy of
those of you who like to use the metric
system I actually like the metric system
as well but we'll just call this a
hundred feet 100 foot long wire and
we're told that we're going to make a
cut someplace on this wire so we're
going to make a cut some place on the
wire and we're going to cut it into two
wires and on the left cut we're going to
turn this into an equilateral triangle
so this left cut right over your the
left the left section of wire we are
going to turn into an equilateral
triangle and the right cut of wire the
right cut of wire we are going to turn
into a square we are going to turn into
a square and the question we are going
we are being asked is where do we make
the cut where do we make the cut in
order to minimize the combined area of
the triangle the equilateral triangle
and the square so where we make the cut
to minimize the combined area so this is
fascinating so let's try to do this so
let's say that X is the distance between
the left hand side and where we make the
cut so let's call this distance right
over here X then what's this distance
right over here going to be in so I'll
do that in the same green color so the
length of the green wire is going to be
X and what's the length of the orange
wire going to be well it's going to be
100 minus X 100 minus X so the length of
this is X what is the area what is the
area of this of this equilateral
triangle going to be well we know what
the lengths of the sides of the
equilateral triangle are going to be
it's going to be x over 3 x over 3 and x
over 3 and so somehow we have to figure
out what the area would be if we know
the sides of an equilateral triangle so
for that I'll do a little bit of an
aside here just to read arrive the area
of an equilateral triangle as a function
of the
length of its sides so let me did a
little bit bigger actually so I can
derive a little bit better so if it has
if an equilateral triangle has sides of
length s s s and s and we were to drop
down an altitude just like that so this
is perpendicular then this length right
over here that I'm going to do in pink
this length right over here is going to
be s over 2 s over 2 and to figure out
the area of a triangle you need to
multiply the base times the height times
one-half so we just need to figure out
what this height is which I will draw in
blue and we could use the Pythagorean
theorem to figure it out so if we call
that height H we know that H squared we
know that H squared plus s over 2
squared plus s over 2 squared plus s
over 2 squared is going to be equal to
the hypotenuse is going to be equal to
or is going to be equal to the
hypotenuse squared is going to be equal
to is going to be equal to s squared is
going to be equal to s squared and so we
just have to solve for H we can subtract
this business from both sides and we get
h squared is going to be equal to s
squared s squared minus this thing which
is s squared over 4 minus s squared over
4 well you could view this if you have a
whole of something minus a fourth of
that something this is going to be equal
to three fourths s squared this is going
to be equal to three fourths s squared
is equal to H squared is equal to a
squared or your height is going to be
equal to the square root of three
fourths s squared so it's going to be
the square root of three times s all of
that all of that over 2 so what's the
area of this thing going to be well it's
going to be the base times the height so
let me write this down the area of this
equilateral triangle is going to be
equal to the base s times the height
which is equal to s
so this thing times the square root of 3
over 2 s which is equal to the square
root of 3 over 2 s squared so there you
have it we got our area as a function of
s of the area of an equilateral triangle
as a function of the length of one of
its sides so based on that the area of
this thing right over here the area is
going to be equal to square root of 3
over 2 times s squared well what's the
length of one of our sides it's x over 3
so we're going to square x over 3 so
this is going to be equal to square root
of 3 times x squared over 3 squared
which is nine times 2 which is 18 so
that is our area our area of our
triangle of our triangle let me write a
sub T so area of our triangle as a
function of X fair enough now let's do
the area of our square as a function of
X so this is a little bit more
straightforward each of the sides are
going to be one-fourth of this so
they're going to be 100 minus x over 4
and then this is going to be 100 minus x
minus x over 4 so the area is just going
to be 100 minus x over 4 squared so it's
just going to be so the area of my
square as a function of X is going to be
100 minus x over 4 squared which is
equal to well let's see it's going to be
100 squared which is 10,000 minus 200 x
minus 200 x plus x squared all of that
all of that over 16 so what's our
combined area going to be well our
combined area our combined area is going
to be and this is what we want to
minimize our combined area as a function
of X is going to be this business it's
going to be square root of 3 over 18 x
squared plus all of this business so
right over here let's see we could
rewrite this as one plus one over
16x squared and then minus 200 / 16 X so
minus 200 / 16 X let's see if you divide
both 200 if you divide both 216 by four
you have 50 50 / 4 X as you can divide
that becomes 25 / 2 so minus 25 / 2 X
and then we have one we have 10,000 / 16
so plus 10,000 / 16 well that's the same
thing as 2,500 over 4 that's the same
thing as 2,500 over for now let's see
four goes into 2500 4 goes into 25 6
times 24 you get a hundred here so it
gets 625 so plus 625 so i could rewrite
this if i want to combine the
coefficients on the x squared term this
is going to be equal to and we get a
quite a quite a hairy expression right
over here square root of 3 over 18 plus
1 over 16 x squared minus 25 over 2x
plus 625 and so this is the thing this
is the thing that we need to minimize
and I'll do that in the next video